bonsoir clos deux raisons question
pourquoi le liban sans fond style est
inexorablement dans une crise économique
qu'on suit maintenant depuis déjà
plusieurs mois
là parce qu'il n'a pas su adapter son
économie aux nouvelles réalités
la crise elle est structurelle le liban
importe quatre ans fois plus qu'ils
n'exportent il importe ses produits
notamment agro alimentaire pour se
nourrir près de 7% du pib ils sont
consacrés et en fait dans les années
fastes
tout ça a été plus ou moins masquée par
le fait que beaucoup de capitaux de la
région à l'est et volontiers sur cette
plateforme financière accueillante que
constituer le liban ça a été le cas dans
les années 50 à 60 pour les capitaux qui
craignaient les nationalisations en
egypte en syrie en irak
ça a été le cas ensuite même pendant la
guerre du liban des capitaux des
capitaux des revenus du pétrole
dans le fond le liban à cette époque est
devenu une sorte de coffre fort pour les
pétrodollars et puis ceci fonctionner
avec un système bancaire en effet sous
capitalisées puisque les flux importants
arrivées d'étrangers y compris les
investissements étrangers
eh bien on n'avait pas besoin de mesures
prudentielles habituel pour les banques
et le capital des banques étaient
notoirement insuffisant tout ça va durer
ne peut nous pouvait durer qu'un temps
et aujourd'hui est bien aidé en pleine
crise on voit bien que l'année dernière
une partie de la dette du liban n'a pas
pu être remboursés c'était donc un
défaut de paiement
la banque centrale s'attaque aujourd'hui
à cette recapitalisation des banques
privées mais elle refuse
l'audit de la banque centrale elle même
que demandent par ailleurs le fmi est
effectivement le fmi ne peut pas aider
le liban tant qu'il n'a pas obtenues
tant qu'il n'est pas au clair sur le
système financier libanais et c'est ce
qu'il a expliqué au liban l'année
dernière déjà bien avant l'explosion
dans le port de beyrouth
donc cette crise elle est antérieure à
l'explosion du port de beyrouth et
aujourd'hui elle atteint son maximum
avec un taux d'inflation de 4 100 % une
proportion de la population active d'un
tiers est environ au chômage et 50 % de
la population est en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté
c'est donc une situation économique tout
à fait dramatique mais pour la redresser
et bien en effet il faut réformer le
système bancaire il faut réformer aussi
sans doute la banque centrale le
directeur de cette banque centrale est
directeur depuis un quart de siècle
c'est un financier avertit qui vient du
secteur pv mais un quart de siècle c'est
peut-être un peu long et est en effet le
liban a l'habitude de traiter avec ces
élites traditionnelles les élites le
président libanais michel aoun estime
que la diaspora peut aider
le liban alors véritablement ce qu'elle
peut jouer un rôle économique important
elle le pourrait si elle se sait le
voulait ce qu'elles se mobilisent et
puisque la diaspora est plus nombreuse
que ne le sont les habitants du liban
même le lit vend ses sept millions
d'habitants et la diaspora
c'est quelque chose qui est entre 7 et
14 millions d'habitants
ça dépend si on prend toutes les
générations seulement les générations
qui ont émigré le plus récemment elles
ont émigré beaucoup en amérique latine
beaucoup aussi en amérique du nord en
afrique en europe en france et celle
émigraient sont évidemment très actif et
généralement ont très bien réussi dans
les affaires
par conséquent il pourrait aider leur
pays d'origine
bien sûr le liban étant ce qu'il est est
un pays où les communautés jouent un
rôle très important
il compte notamment les communautés
religieuses c'est ed passerait sans
doute par les communautés religieuses et
plus certainement encore par les réseaux
familiaux des familles détendu puisque
le liban l'économie du liban repose en
quelque sorte sur quelques sur quelques
grandes familles et le président aoun
fait un appel pour qu'ils viennent à
l'aide du dpi
ils ne le feront que s'ils ont confiance
dans l'équipe qui dirige le libre en or
actuellement ce n'est pas le cas et ce
n'est pas le cas pour la communauté
internationale ce ne sera pas le cas non
plus pour la diaspora alors le pays du
cèdre pas de gouvernement c1 depuis
maintenant six mois pourquoi est ce si
difficile d'en former un
c'est probablement parce que les
contraintes politiques à l'intérieur et
les pressions qui viennent de
l'extérieur sont trop fortes et ne
permettent pas de constituer un
gouvernement
donc actuellement on a un gouvernement
qui expédie les affaires courantes qui
est celui qui était en place au mois
d'août
il ya eu plusieurs tentatives pour
former un gouvernement par des
technocrates dont une équipe dirigée par
l'ancien ambassadeur
à berlin une autre tentative par
monsieur hariri lui-même est revenu et
ses tentatives ont échoué
elles ont échoué pourquoi et bien
notamment parce que l'habitude a été
prise d'un partagé ministère et
notamment le hezbollah réclamant un
droit de regard voire une sorte de
propriété sur des ministères où
circulent l'argent est actuellement le
gouvernement qui expédie les affaires
courantes comporte deux ministres issus
du hezbollah plus de ministre issu du
parti cavale qui est proche du hezbollah
est en effet ses ministres contrôle le
ministère des finances
le messin la santé et le ministère de
l'industrie
ce qui montre bien la difficulté parce
que ce que demande la communauté
internationale est ce que voudrait aussi
sans doute la diaspora c'est que ce
partage du gâteau cesse et qu'on ait des
gouvernements efficace et puisse se
mettre les réformes qui s'imposent en
oeuvre de façon à ce que la communauté
internationale vienne en aide à ce pays
merci claude blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales